oh you can perfect
[Music]
perfect
hey what's up everybody I'm Thomas
dopagiola whatever you want to call me
I'm with my co-host Marty O'Neill what's
up guys what's up this is dope as usual
podcast we're going to talk about life
drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between today we have a
very special episode humanitarian actor
musician and Avid art collector this is
Cheech Marin hey how you are thanks for
being thanks for being I'm good I'm
always I think I'm awake now thank you
for being here I know it was a long trip
so appreciate it yeah I had a passport
and shots on everything to get here man
I just got passports
thanks now thank you for coming um I
just want to get right into this real
quick I met you one time yeah eight
years ago before I ever started doing oh
type of stuff was you in the restaurant
no no no no no no no no no but I rolled
a gigantic joint like this I hope he
wants to smoke it yeah and I walked up
and I'm like hey check out this joint
man I rolled it oh you're smoking you're
like I love it it's gonna be great
tonight
I was like I don't think you heard me no
he heard you perfectly
ah you know what at least at least I got
it to him what a g okay thank you be
great tonight you'd have to approach
with care
um but no thank you so much for being
here oh my pleasure and I know we were
talking about before we started we got
right into it uh your Cheech is stash
teaches stash I know what is it in all
stores in California uh a lot of them a
lot of them and not in California but in
what legal states seven every other
states oh so everything that's legal
basically here in that market yeah well
you know as many as we can get into but
we're all over the country right now you
know man and as soon as it gets legal
federally we'll be in in every damn
State and the automatic name brand
recognition right off the bat you know
it's just ridiculous I mean they're
creeping towards that they're inching
towards it now next year it is just just
yesterday there's a lot of uh
propositions to make uh we legal
federally and that's that's the big big
uh border crossing there if you will as
soon as they make it Federal legally
then you can be like any other business
like you'd be like Cheerios you can be
manufactured in General Mills and sold
in Arizona you can't do that with weed
right now yeah and your but your Meats a
lot is coming out
it's a michelada with weed no but with a
non-alcoholic beer so it tastes just
like a michelada but it has as a six day
well you know a lot of weed in it I
don't even know slogan was a it's like a
michelada with some Cheech in it with
some cheese in it that's what it is and
it's great it's taste it's a great
tasting drink I don't know if
everybody's familiar with Micheladas but
it's like you know it's a Mexican hair
of the dog that bit you you know in the
morning you're kind of little little
ragged and having michelada everything's
nice why is that why is biking all this
made me sick I need a little bit more to
make it you know it is I mean you know
like I I've drank it since I was able to
drink in the olden days but it really
works really well and this is a
particularly good drink you know and
that drops next month yeah uh we have an
opening on Friday from two to five at
the woods on Santa Monica Boulevard and
Hollywood and come Woody Harrelson my
buddy's place and uh come on down and
celebrate with us because it's going to
be really good nice nice um while you're
on the topic of you're talking about
legalization and federal legalization
I I just I don't know how I never
noticed it in Nice Dreams you're wearing
a normal shirt yeah yeah how many times
I've seen that never noticed that you're
wearing a normal shirt it was in English
that's why
I just never noticed they're still
around today yeah yeah 30 years ago yeah
it was I was it was the first t-shirt I
picked up in the morning we shot that
that scene in a house like two houses
away from where I was living and I
thought hey you got to go to work though
I gotta walk to work okay so I walked up
the beach went to work and I just
grabbed the first t-shirt I found and I
didn't put it on and I didn't even know
what it was blue I said okay I don't
think I wore a blue shirt and then oh
normal oh that works the organization
trying to stop the
federal crimes of possession and
basically what we're trying to do now
normal started in the 70s could you have
pictured back then like 30 40 years from
now will still be kind of fighting this
being some of the first people to start
that fight yeah you know I I thought it
would be much quicker than it has been
you know I mean it's like it's like
being kind to pregnant right now
can't do much
okay
there's a new kind of baby coming here I
I you know you just look at the price
and the weirdest states have the this
most stringent Laws Texas Texas is no
place normally in in Texas you can smoke
with and the biggest dopers in the world
that I know are from Texas 100
Willie Nelson since the very beginning
yeah it's the very beginning it's just
you can't have joints you can have
rifles yeah at the store
I've been to Texas once and I was like
in your Easy Rider rifle rack here right
here in my truck exactly the rifle rack
but you can't have any type of ball with
it but they do have weed I mean you know
weed cuts through every single segment
of a society whether you're conservative
or liberal or what whatever you are
everybody smokes weed yeah that's what I
noticed when I got older at first I
thought I was like no it's just got to
be the the skater kids and then I found
like my cousins smoke weed the doctor or
the the accountant are you shocked by
the people that come up to you that like
wow I wouldn't have packed you for a
[__] weed smoker but it's gotta be
all of them pegged me for a week or the
other way around have you ever seen like
wow this father of nine yeah well my dad
was a policeman yes for 30 years that's
all at LAPD 30 years though a lot of my
family were law enforcement you know so
I was the most paranoid Family Reunion
yeah I know it was like I used to have
it
I couldn't understand so I just kind of
was on the QT and then away we went when
I got off the leash I went to college
you know that was the first time I was
off the ace band and the first time I
smoked a joint was handed to me at the
party and I took a hit and I go
and what else has been lying about it
you know that's your first time smoking
yeah the first time and what else
they've been lying about man this is not
exactly what they've been telling me
like everything was fine the music
sounded good everybody was having a good
time and you said you know hmm I better
investigate this
further in the next 70 years I think I
should do some experiments
it is I mean it is and everywhere you go
you know that's yeah every I don't you
know no place that I've been in the last
50 years has not had Weed really no
place well speaking of a 50 year Marty
can you pop that up real quick we saw a
post on your social media it said 50
years ago today
yeah wow oh
my God
a concert at Curtis Hixson Hall in Tampa
Florida very famous Hall that they'd
arrested everybody there uh Janice
Joplin Jim Morrison oh wow but the deal
was that the guys who ran the hall there
was a there was a ordinance of the hall
that if you broke any of the precepts of
the hall or you know did anything bad or
and there was a police report they
complained the promoter no the the hall
owners could withhold five thousand
dollars from the promoter and that's
what they did and so scammers it was a
scam and and so we did two shows that
tonight in the same Hall with Dr John
and the night Tripper he was he opened
up for us and so they said oh both Souls
sold out shows okay we were going to run
this scam and this so they had the
police make a complaint you know about
oh these guys are here walking around
like dogs and blah blah blah he pissed
on my head it talks like you know like
because the stage was really higher and
the cops were standing right in front of
the stage looking out at the audience so
I was doing the dogs I ran over the
artist lifting my leg and peed on top of
the car cop's head you know I think
that's was kind of like the deal but uh
but they they were they you know so we
got taken to jail there we got released
eventually and there was no uh uh
charges filed but we got a cool mug shot
you ever seen the Tommy's half of the
version he's like he's like yeah like it
looks like right
totally in the shadows man it looks wild
um yeah so they basically said oh we're
gonna scam you you guys did great and
why wouldn't they the cops like give me
a thousand I'll take it down you know I
get it it was the same Hall Curtis
Hixson Curtis Hixson Hall in Tampa
Florida they they're judging people
Janice Joplin and Jim Morrison they're
just picking up anybody that has weed in
their green room if we're gonna arrest
you know I don't know the funny thing
was like so we got off stage after the
last show and our road manager just
Jimmy root and he's and he's and he's
running around the dressing room putting
stuff away or doing this I said well
Jimmy what you doing you guys are going
to get arrested as soon as as a show in
or the cops coming what for what he
explained it to me well that's why I
said what did you do is I'm hiding all
the weed well we ain't got any weed we
just got here you know
so he got All Shook Up and then they
took us away we went but the cops argued
about who was going to take us to
because
they both had the records
had all the records you know I'll get to
take him man I want to hear some of the
bits and they started doing bits for us
man and then they put this put us in the
Paddy Wagon and the way we went you know
and then they made the rest of their
drunk routes you know they go pick up
other people [__] other people throw
them in there people that had crap their
drawers man or are thrown up they're
like oh Jesus I just had two sold out
shows
yeah could you imagine like I'm drunk
and she ain't getting a cheetahs [__] is
going on in here all right and then they
put us in the other thing right like
that it was a long night we finally got
out
well have you ever played there again uh
yeah yeah
actually that we came back like in about
less than a year later and we sold out
three shows did they pull the scam on
you no no they played a different Hall
oh okay I got you 999 you guys you're
gonna get no more of our money no way
yeah
there was stuff that that happened all
the time you know but then there was we
never the cops were our buds you know I
mean they they were our biggest fans
really I know I mean like you said all
walks alive you wouldn't expect it's a
cop arresting me he's my fan yeah no
that absolutely happened now all the
time you know I can tell you the amount
of times I've had interact interactions
with the police department and they let
me go oh really just based on I can't do
this to this guy exactly hey you know I
hear your dad was a cop okay here you go
hey can you can we take a picture selfie
here we go I almost hit a cop one time I
I was in Malibu's driving back and I was
I didn't see him I wanted to change
later as a motorcycle guy and I I didn't
say I was coming back from playing golf
and I was all tired and everything and I
almost hit him
and I wanted a guy comes and he comes up
to the window gets off his bike and
comes oh hey it's you hey
come over yeah
I guess okay sometimes that it doesn't
work out like that but yeah so being
who you are I mean obviously you're
you're growing up you're not you smoked
in college but your dad's LAPD yeah how
was that growing up after your records
are now charting oh you're walking in
with you hey what's up that's your kid
yeah that was a little Richard that was
the biggest time of his life I you know
because he could get free records from
me so and then hand them out to all the
jewelry delinquents man and that one
says hey
what's going on over here man who it's
like it's exactly how it worked why
being the neighborhood right exactly
radical one over here it is oh they were
glad to get the record so they were like
of course I couldn't imagine I would not
believe that cop in one bit yeah yeah
that's me and that's seeing the last
name same oh okay
all right so that's awesome to be
supported from the start or did it take
a while for him to kind of warm up to
the end no no as soon as anything free
man
it's free and it was always as soon as I
came over to visit Hey where's some free
records
yeah all the time we didn't have merch
in those days we just like get free
records you know like but once once we
got merch and then the whole family got
in yeah now it's a business I was saying
last
two episodes ago I think the a Cheech
and Chong shirt might be the most famous
weed shirt in the culture if you think
about it that's the most worn shirt of
any single cartoon any design any of
this you know what it's really weird
when you see a Cheech and Chong Church
especially the cartoons ones and when
those guys from uh uh uh cops or jail
wearing them they're wearing jeans
and it's always the most yellow of all
the guys
okay
I have a question I uh I was thinking
about it and I think there's probably
seven ways to ask it but I want to ask
like probably the most
vast I mean not vast the easiest way I
should say how did you meet Robert
Rodriguez and get into this universe
that you've been in for 20 years because
you have I've still told like it's like
Adam Sandler you know that man is going
to be his friend's gonna be in that
movie like where's Cheech oh glass I got
you yes I'm still working with Robert I
I I heard about him we were already
teaching genre and Rich and Famous I
know made me more famous than rich but
in many ways and and we heard this this
kid from Texas had this movie and he
made for seven thousand dollars and it
was a height of the uh the independent
film Circle and he was getting a lot of
at festivals and he was going to come to
LA and make his first movie and so I
said okay well that just sounds like
good I want to see this movie so finally
I met him at some event the Director's
Guild or something and he says like
going up on your records and your movies
and you know like me and my whole family
had like
10 brothers and sisters yeah wow yeah
the same there was 10 kids five girls
and five boys and and we will always
listen to them and blah blah blah and
watch the movies
because I want you to be in my next my
movie I'm going to make movies yeah it
sounds good kid as soon as you get some
money give me a call yeah that's what he
gave me a call I got the money from the
studio blah blah let's go
cool let's go and then there was eight
movies in a row after that you know it
was so now Robert and I are teaming up
together uh to he's going to Institute a
program at the Cheech which is my own my
private Museum uh it's kind of art
museum art in Riverside California and
he's going to Institute a film program
there at the Chase and teach that uh
seven seven thousand dollars to make a
movie wow that's awesome yeah and so
we're gonna keep on that practice you
know so Robert and I have been buddies
forever you know the first one what was
the first movie he made Desperado
Desperado no he made Mariachi Mary asked
you for four that's see it's almost like
a prequel but it's not because Danny
Trejo's alive in the second one because
he got stabbed up in the first ones yeah
so okay see that's one of the questions
I had like did they just say hey he's
good actor just just make him alive
again yeah he can do that yes so that
that's that was the first one El
Mariachi right yeah and that was he made
that when he was a student in the
University of Texas
and with a borrowed camera and you know
everything he could do to get for free
he made it and so he kind of what he
teaches in this program is how to do
every single job in the movie making
process it's not just director you're
the writer or whatever you're you're the
gaffer you're the caterer you're the guy
that handles the trucks you know you got
to know how to do every job that's how
you can make it for seven thousand
dollars so seven thousand to make that
movie with Antonio Banderas in it was
someone hike in that first one too no
she wasn't she was she was desperate
there was uh Antonio I thought he was oh
no it was the other three that he teamed
up with in Desperados or the machine gun
with the thing Carlos something or other
and uh yeah no no but he was the and
then that was the that was the first
introduction no it was the second
introduction they ever saw to uh Danny
Trejo he was in running rate train first
in the 80s yeah it was with uh Eric
Roberts and John Voight and she
konchalowski director Russian director
because he just got on our out of prison
you know and he was in this a theater
acting group in prison I think it was
George Abbott or something Abbott had
started this group and he was part of it
and so he was looking for a job as an
actor when he got I mean he didn't know
anything I mean ZIP he knew armed
robbery
[Laughter]
but he didn't know anything about how
did the movie making process process and
uh and so he got it they were looking
for somebody on this movie that they
could teach either I think Eric Roberts
had a box and Danny Trejo was a
middleweight champion of the prison
in one of the prisons you know and uh
and so yeah I could do that you know but
he was like straight out of prison had
nobody nowhere to go man nothing zip and
he got a job and he like he slept in the
Box Car they were wow I mean and he you
know and he went up every at the end of
the first day okay where's my money you
know well no they pay it too at the end
of the week or the month a month and so
but that's how we started and then I
struggle our our pictures it was the
second thing he did and he did every
single one of them
that's crazy how it keeps going you said
you're working on more too besides the
the school any any other films with Rob
Rodriguez or
um not that he's called me
I need some other guys to do eight in a
row here I remember it was Grindhouse I
remember when that came out the double
feature I haven't seen that in a long
time in the theater I went and watched
them both they had the break we went
outside smoking joint came back in it
wasn't that cool yes very cool well that
was started by because we did this
trailer for the non-existent film we
were shooting something else I was I was
in Texas at Austin where he has his
studio and he says hey come out to the
the parking lot and we'll shoot this
this thing it's not it's for a fake
movie the movie doesn't exist where
we're shooting an ad for it you know
like a tree and he come up with it with
a shotgun and blah blah blah blah and
you and you're a priest okay sounds good
I can do that and uh pretty sure the
Shaka hey right up my alley okay so so
he comes down nice we shoot this little
thing in the park that was it there was
no movie there was nothing
and so they they put it out on the
internet and it got so much attention
because everybody said well where's the
movie we want to see this movie and
there was so much rattle going on about
it that the studio all right well let's
make this movie that's how it started
yeah you know we didn't you wouldn't
think that just a spoof now let's tease
him oh you want it that bad yeah and it
was it was from Brian house who put the
ad in Brian house and the movie didn't
exist
I mean I've watched that movie countless
time so I I understand that nice it's
going into it knowing they want it is
way better even if they go you're going
to know when they want it they gotta
have it they still take their damn time
it's like
it's called shell out falter when they
got a shell out they falter
I thought it was an awesome term I've
never heard shut up falter man do you I
mean I know it's kind of early do you do
you want to smoke or anything well if
you if you put it like that it's got a
little light I got some joints I'll bust
that one out
later as long as I don't have to drive
you know no no we still got our driver
yeah okay cool give me thank you sir
here you go and then Marty I think there
should be a lighter right next to you
yeah there is always an effect
oh my God so this message is brought to
you by my bookie this entire season all
season long for NFL and college football
they're bringing you a brand new cash
out system with multiple options to bet
and win so if you're going to be betting
online this season go to mybookie.ag and
use our promo code dope as usual you can
register for a free account and once you
do use our code dope as usual at
checkout and you're gonna get one free
chip for the my bookie casino and for me
to you it's a free chip if you're gonna
win let it ride it was free all of us
great advice but Bobby betting lately
okay so make the free account once you
use your first deposit use our promo
code you're gonna get that free chip to
use my Boogie Casino remember you can
bet anything anytime anywhere using my
bookie supercontest free beds odds Booth
all season long with my bookie remember
use code dope as usual and get that free
chip for the casino so make the free
account once you use your first deposit
use our promo code you're gonna get that
free chip to use my Boogie Casino
remember you can bet anything anytime
anywhere using mybookie.ag super contest
free beds odds boost all season long
with my bookie remember use code dope as
usual and get that free chip for the
casino what's up guys taking a moment to
talk about one of our spa sponsors and
that is mint mobile you guys already
know mint mobile is offering the lowest
phone plans that you could possibly find
unlimited talk and text high-speed data
delivered on the largest 5G Network
everything I just said is included in
the mint Mobile plans starting off at
just 15 a month gas groceries the movies
everything is inflating money is going
up everything's expensive and mint
Mobile's going the opposite direction
they're making it cheaper to the
customer and that is a win for all of us
so right now go to mintmobile.com
forward slash Yola to activate the 15 a
month plan remember unlimited talk text
high-speed data on the largest 5G
Network in America you can sign up for
mint mobile directly from your home
anywhere you just don't even have to go
to the store you can do it completely
online and that's how they have passed
the savings on to you no more upsell
here at the store all the savings go
directly to you no waiting no lines and
you can go from any phone service it's
not like you have to have something
compatible anything will work they will
switch you right over and get start
saving today
nice
now see this is an example of Hera the
dog that [__] are you too high last
night
I'm tired today I think I'm awake yeah
that's me when I get editable that's
what I meant by the serum yeah it's like
I mean I
some people sleep really well with weed
I'm one of those guys I sleep and some
people don't
I'm glad I'm one of those guys that do
because I like my sleep and I also like
being awake and going to the movies and
going to the restaurants
besides I mean I couldn't tell you how
many times I've seen you pop up oh [__]
in movies with the voice acting how did
you get into the lot I mean you if
you're a fan you know like oh it's his
voice I can hear it right here so was it
cars
Lion King fantasy was it fantasy there
was like treasure there was like six
other cartoons
Oliver and Company there you go do you
know what it was was that was our
training
because of the albums were always all
voices with all voices
Oh voiceless man she's so animated you
do improv you're on stage you're doing
sketch you're involving the audience and
I was that was one of my questions how
do you express your voice it's that
inflation you already have it yeah we
had you know six albums worth of that
and a Grammy winner and a Grammy winner
we were nominated by a grant for a
Grammy with every single album we did oh
really just snagged one which one was it
for I think it was for uh wedding album
I think it was the wedding album got it
but we were like I never thought I at
the first year I didn't think we were
gonna you know because we were brand new
you know but we got nominated and uh and
then every one after then so after that
I thought well
next are the Big Bamboo certainly is
going to get a Grammy now and then kept
going and finally we snagged one and
then then I didn't care after that
well I don't need two
you know when you get to a point like
the Grammy I don't need another one let
me know your albums are doing good yeah
they're doing they're doing you know
which award we did when every year was
the National Association of record
merchandises award that's a dramatic you
sold the most albums that year of the
year including music or or
for comedy but but we had three number
one albums in a row crazy three hearted
number one yeah number one oh I didn't
realize what our competition was
man that was Pink Floyd and the rest of
the guys on the record industry are you
know are our promoters buddies and
they're all pissed off at it man you're
taking room up to on the charts man
where music could be
you come on wow I didn't realize you're
competing with Led Zeppelin in sales of
Records yeah yeah
see because we occurred right in the
start of the Baby Boomers buying albums
before that rock and roll was singles he
had singles or Elvis Presley Jerry Lee
Lewis and all the singles and then all
of a sudden the whole album concept
started coming there was albums before
but the concept of having like a concept
album yeah started happening you know
and then and then record sales went from
like to get a gold record she had to
sell 400 like a 450 000 units of
something it wasn't a million it was
like a million dollars or so however
they calculated it but uh you had to
sell that one Lord have gold records so
it was you know big deal but when we
signed up with Lou Adler who was our
first uh was only producer really and
and uh he was just about to release uh
tapestry by Carol King
from not not I mean to have a gold
record to sell 450 000 albums it's a big
deal she sold 15 million 15 million 15
million in the 70s yeah and early 70s
yeah I mean it was like
it was like she was in another race
you know and then it started happening
so we were right along with okay now you
can sell a lot of and then we were we
were the rock and roll comedians you
know 100 and I'm I'm still pissed off
that we're not in the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame which we should be in oh I never
thought about that I mean if you're
outside and you're selling these records
and you're doing these things
Rock X recovery in our [__]
we knew had number one hits uh uh
Basketball Jones was the number one
single
yeah Eric my eye number one single
uh yeah I know I get oh you'd be a
little upset now well you know like I
belong there yeah no one there and
everybody
we have uh what was that band from
Seattle uh like no it was right in that
area the not Coldplay not Coldplay but
REM something from their Flags Seattle
Foo Fighters no Chris Connelly
it's not Audioslave that's the second
part yeah what's the first one that
sings Black Hole Sun come on
I know what you're talking about stump
for a comeback here
I know exactly Chris Connelly yeah yeah
and and they covered like my corn they
covered your music yeah so they're
getting hits off of your head
sound garden there you go Sun Garden
right and Stanley Turrentine covered
black Lassie which was another hit
um you know I never even thought about
these things in terms of music because
it's always so funny you don't think
like no that's a hit
when other rock and rollers are covering
your [__] man yeah that's that's the
proof you know I didn't even think of
that I mean there wasn't one guitarist
are you budding guitarist or any
guitarist at that time that didn't know
that riff
and it all played for us so whenever we
saw hey watch this
my cousin Ralph uh he's in the record
industry and he asked me to ask you yeah
did you get any records at the Battle of
the Bands because those were all real
Punk fans oh yeah yeah I mean because
you're in the music did you do you have
any of that stuff
uh they were all the bands were hanging
out in the Sunset Strip you know right
at that time guess we're being a movie
Circle Jerks and those guys yeah
yeah that's how that went down yeah
that's how it went down yeah because the
Roxy was the center of that you know
they were oh the Roxy yes yes exactly
yeah and our producer Lou Adler owned
the Roxy that was at the Roxy just from
the left and that means the rainbows to
my left how did I not realize that I
don't know I smoked so much weed in that
place that is physically impossible not
to remember that but
you're the Curve
um so you get into uh the voice acting
sorry
the circle Back The Lion King how do you
get approach or do you approach somebody
that I want to be a voice in The Voice
the first one I went it was before The
Lion King was Oliver and Company and
Tommy and I had just split up and I was
like okay what am I gonna do now and
this call came in they were going to do
this all over in company which was like
Oliver Twist but it was animated and
would I come in to read for one of the
things you know say okay cool and I
never done uh uh you know kind of that
voice acting from movies before I just
you albums which was really good
training as we come to find out uh and
so I went in there and and all the guys
were in there and
they gave me the the stuff they wanted
to say and I did it and it was just I I
was new it was for like I did I was
unsure of myself and they go okay well
that's good thank you very much for
coming in and uh and I went out of the
parking lot that [__] sucked oh man
I'm gonna go back in there so I went
back in there and I said I think that
what I did it sucked I want to do it
again and so they were okay well cool
and uh and George Scribner who was the
director it was an interesting guy grew
up in Panama but spoke Spanish you know
so but he was I think his folks were in
the military
and I said do you have any direction for
me or something that says play it like
you you got your finger stuck in the in
the light socket man and I go got it I
went back in man yeah yeah full blast
every single [__] letter in there
and at the end of it man you can see all
the all the animators are starting to
watch and draw me
like and then okay cool all right the
next session is going to be blah blah
blah blah blah and then and so the next
year and a half I was on that movie wow
and I still I can't I I'd come out every
one of those sessions Raw
you know because you're just like yeah
full force and uh it was a big hit and
it was the first in the regime of
Jeffrey katzenberg who was the director
of the head of Disney at the time it was
a first in this in the new series of
animated films that are coming out
the next one was The Lion King and and
Jeffrey told me on that we were skiing
together in in Deer Valley we both had
places there we was getting we were
riding up uh they left and because he
was he was he worked up in smoke for for
Paramount so we knew each other real
well and this is I got this i got this
animated film coming up and you're gonna
be in it then blah blah blah okay when
we do that well three years from now
three years from now what are you
telling me now man
and so he's a bit three years later but
called me up in Lion King and changes
changed animated history
wow and then one after the other the
line stacking cars uh
did they expect Lion King to be so
legendary and huge when they're making
it
I I think maybe they did because you
know I started on the film and it was
like okay as you know animals are jungle
in there okay and then they start
showing me halfway into like the
drawings I go oh oh this is this is oh
you don't see it first no no you do the
voice first Oh I thought maybe you would
be watching the guy move the line or the
honeymoon or the voiceover it's exactly
the opposite oh this whole time all the
BTS they show in documentaries yeah
they're looking at it yeah no no you do
the voice first and they animate to you
to your voice that makes sense at the
beginning there's a lot of artists and
they're drawing you here the way you
make your facial expressions and stuff
like that and then they put together a
sequence and they show it to you and
they go okay can you give me this and so
you do that from then they draw that and
so then you see like
quite a ways into the process you see a
sequence that they put together and it's
not fully animated but almost and when
they showed me that I go oh this is a
whole different deal man they're doing
rack Focus shots in this in this movie
on a yeah
[Music]
oh okay we're into something else here
and then you hear the music yeah it's
the music you can score on that which is
that was an interesting time because it
was right on the brink of like
technology really with computers and
stuff was it really was it on the
digital side or was it not just because
they came out in in CBS CDs
the compact disc was in
um not only affected the record industry
but the movie industry at the same time
the LA the soundtrack for Lion King sold
15 million copies on the on the first
pass come on first pass
and that is you know when they when they
you brought me in to do the uh was it
the like and they were doing
I can't I think they were doing a Beauty
and the Beast or something you know
where the where the scene where Belle
walks through the town
and everybody comes out of their their
colleges and you meet all the characters
man and it took me and it showed me that
sequence
in
eight different languages the same
sequence and in the sequence all of a
sudden the language would change from
English to Spanish and it sounded like
the same person singing
and then French and then Dutch and then
Afrikaans or what you know what okay
okay I'll do this you know sir why not
you know and because and everything was
booming at that point right it's like
because they could do things digitally
that's when whole the blue screen
started to happen oh sorry yeah so it's
you know and that's why records were
routinely selling five million 10
million copies even think the soundtrack
to the well kids want to listen to it oh
man oh man look at the YouTuber YouTube
songs by billions of views on it so I
understand translate into 15 million
sales easy quick easy I mean that was
the first round okay the movie's been
out a month 15 minutes
like okay but we were getting used to
that at the same time because Carol King
had sold 15 million tapestries
you know like it was like
I don't know it's like like winning by
99 yards in the 100 yard dash
two kids ever recognize you just off
your voice I know their parents go oh my
God it's cheating they go no I know that
voice you know it's funny how that works
kids little kids you know like you know
little kids they don't have no idea so
how I am and then the people and their
parents tell them
I remember my good friend man had twin
girls and and they were at that age and
yeah yeah your friends and and this is
have you ever seen any animated films
yeah uh with which one have you seen
have you seen The Lion King yeah
uh well we'll just eat whatever lying
around and they look up at me like I
don't know Johnny Depp just landed
and they would follow me around after
that like oh you do that do it do it
again do it again
I wish I could do that oh come on hey
Luke you want to light up for the rest
of your week ah just say something to
him it's amazing you know that that uh
it's uh
it was it's nice to experience that
because it is just like you have to be
realize that for what it is you know
like this as you have soaked into the
culture on many generations and
different levels too The Counter Culture
of mainstream culture kids adults
everybody the most of County cultures
and that's something else I wanted to
say
even now like we make videos like on my
other side we have the biggest Wii
channel on YouTube right that's why I do
like the biggest craziest stuff we roll
cheese and Chong so all joins with a
girl monsters and um we have so much
pushback the pushback you you must have
gotten
while you're making your films and then
Up in Smoke there's 100 million dollars
in in the box office in the 70s
now that's a Smash Hit 10 years that's
still a Smash Hit but in the 70s on a
movie that most people have to sneak out
to go watch yeah yeah yeah it was it was
interesting timing movie making for
Studio wise right that we made
up and smoke at the same time that
Heaven's Gate was being made Heaven's
Gate I don't know you're not familiar
with that proves my point uh Heaven's
Gate was a big epic coming to the West
uh cowboy movie kind of uh uh Michael
Cimino was the director here just made
Deer Hunter oh okay the last one it was
his first move and he won the Academy
Award his best director and everybody it
was supposed to be the big deal uh
Heaven's gained a lot of money and it
was for and we our little tiny movie Man
looked up and smoke you know eight
hundred thousand dollars and uh and and
and Heaven's Gate palapo and and uh and
up in smoke a lot of money so it was a
big change in the movie industry at that
point now they started listening oh you
got something crazy it sounds good to us
so with the pushback even with the film
industry did you see did you did was
that did that affect you
let's go to the premiere do you really
want these guys at our Premiere no no no
as soon as it starts making money hey oh
okay you're right you're right where
you've been all my life it's a good
point that is a good point actually the
thing is is
what was different about the movies it
was around the world simultaneously in
every language it's either dubbed or
subtitled but at the same time because
around the world you could listen to the
records but they're all in English
so how are you going to speak French and
German and Italian and Japanese but that
when that started happening
then you you really got recognized you
know from wherever you went driving down
the freeway and people pointing at you
and we had been living in in France for
a couple years Tommy and I both and and
then
you know all right let's pull over and
talk about it man
they've seen them move let's go over and
talk about it yeah
my dad used to do that to pull over and
talk about it guys
he was a policeman man
literally pulling you over to talk about
it yeah no no with knowing your civilian
car with your kids in the car and like
some guy will start giving you some
something huh why don't we pull over and
talk about it I'm gonna drive off that's
a chilly
now anybody that's calm and asks you
that I'm just going to keep going I
apologize exactly right how did you guys
end up living in France uh we made a
movie there oh it's Corsican Brothers
and we did uh night old old school yeah
and then we did a lot of pre-production
on it and that's about six months I shot
the moon and that's another three oh I
gotcha and then we just we're digging it
you know yeah yeah how's France how was
that it was wonderful what did you like
what was the difference of of being walk
walk down the street here can you walk
down the street there and not get
bombarded yeah it was just there
actually this summer uh yeah it was
great in those days you know because we
were like making a movie in another
country and then didn't speak English
that much uh it was great yeah we had a
good time in it and our kids were doing
something there
see Robbie and Ray Don Tommy's kids
Robbie was a big rap model uh for all
the big designers and oh really yeah she
was Carl lagerfeld's Muse uh and Ray Don
was a ray Don Chong she was a big movie
star making movies there and they were
friends with like a lot of people that
were living there and we had this great
apartment man through other friends that
Mick Jagger and Jerry Hall moved out and
me and my wife moved in
and it was like
I don't feel like I couldn't feel any
cooler right now yeah you know you could
hit the Arctic Triumph with a rock from
my balcony man it was like it was right
there and it was like so hey this is
let's enjoy this life for a little while
you know because different than east L.A
it's different than anywhere a little
different but it was it was and then
Tommy lived there for
four years
oh he bought a place and they've done
the kids grew up in French schools and
you know wow what's their stance on weed
there uh I haven't found out I guess
it's okay we smoked it wasn't a problem
it wasn't like scary to be there with
the weed and I they didn't even know
what it is they had hash oh yeah yeah
they didn't have no weight oh okay
interesting in all your travels I'm
wondering and all your time your career
smoking weed around the world has there
been a strain or a particular time that
stands out if you had to think about it
my sister and her husband uh they used
to grow weed Afghani weed Afghan and
it's a little short dwarf almost a dwarf
plant and it's like about that high and
really dark green and real broad leaves
and that was beyond real man
so your sister grows weed well she did
she did so I gotta ask how how many
brothers and sisters do you have uh I
have four sisters
no brothers no brothers You're the only
I was the only boy in the in the family
for my whole generation
yeah yeah that was named Marine it was
other boy Robles and but I was in Marine
wow all right so growing I was just
trying to think of what is the other
thing like oh we want to go to the
movies that's my brother oh is my
brother put in this movie out because
you don't really think you always think
your favorite actor what is their family
how does this affect my dad's a cop that
gives away free Rick see that's what I
want to hear like you know he loved the
records you give him to the hoodlums go
give me some information that's amazing
it's incredible but the thing the other
anomaly in my family is it was we were
all clergy
really yeah I was I was on my way to the
junior Seminary my clothes were there I
passed the things got certified I was
going to graduated from eighth grade
going to ninth grade but at a junior
Seminary
and uh what what yeah but my other two
cousins they had gone to the Seminary
you know and and a Franciscan seminary
in Santa Barbara they had gone Regine
was student body president and then
instead of going to the real Seminary
you know when you really start to be a
priest he went to Harvard instead
and it became the first recipient of of
a doctorate in Chicano studies from
Harvard University oh my God and your
family yeah he was my cousin that's
amazing and the other cousin was was
this genius got a scholarship to grade
school
really and then every school after that
right and I was this little puppy dog
trying to catch up with him you know so
Rosalie was a nun for 30 years
dear family that's really you almost
became a I would have never had any of
this none of this man what an iconic
image of his police dad handing a kid
the vinyl him in the back with the
priest outfit on like 30 years later
like come out with a shotgun yeah all
right come out with a shotgun all right
I made it to the priesthood no I was I
was on my way and then I started going
to parties in the eighth grade
graduation that summer you know like I
said wait a minute I mean there's no
girls in this priesthood oh you know
what I mean maybe I gotta rethink this
yeah oh for the rest of my life yeah
none none girls not just nuns not just
none none not even on the weekends no
okay
and so then so shout out to the hormones
for saving uh the weed cultry industry
and culture
what's up guys I am super excited to
talk about this next sponsor and this is
Hamilton devices Hamilton devices.com go
ahead and check out the website and I
gotta be honest guys even if this wasn't
a sponsor and you showed me this stuff I
would lose my mind see this right here
this is called the jet stream you could
put three different flavor pens in here
this is not like a regular battery
foreign
this is called the kr1 this is a
concentrate and cartridge bubbler you
put water in this piece to hit your cart
and this next thing right here is called
the butterfly the second I saw this I
lost my mind
it's like a butterfly knife but it has
your pen in it this is a battery
remember go to Hamilton devices.com to
check out everything there is countless
items so if you want to step up your
battery life and your battery game go to
Hamilton devices.com and go check out
the site also go ahead and check out
Hamilton devices on Instagram and let
them know the dope as usual podcast sent
you or you saw it here this thing is
incredible hey what's up guys want to
introduce one of our brand new sponsors
this is board hash 100 fresh frozen live
resin this right here is Fruity Pebbles
this here is mochi and a classic string
coming in strong this is gg4 I actually
have the manufacturers behind this and
this is out of his brand new facility
I'm super stoked super happy to have
them as a sponsor I'm gonna be honest I
think the packaging and the die cut is
pretty awesome you have the little
stoned board ape on the front whole
plant fresh frozen remember that 100
live resin fresh frozen let's [__] these
open as you can see it's the same little
logo cut out as the gummy so it has all
the flavors on it remember 10 milligrams
a piece there's grape strawberry orange
lemon and blue raspberry 100 vegan in
and gluten-free that's board hash on
Instagram go ahead and give them a
follow let them know you saw him on the
double as usual podcast they're coming
to the legal Market super stoked the
little pods I like these shapes right
here they're like a hash Ross and
looking pods these are awesome like I
said 100 live resin guys thank you so
much for watching guys back to the
episode
wow who would have thought I honestly I
can't believe I thought you were joking
when you said we're all on the clergy
like are you serious no no there was and
there was you know we weren't the only
ones you know some of the other cousins
too were like you know and that's just a
family it was a family thing well you
went to Catholic we all went to Catholic
school and that stuff is just uh
hammered you know they would pay for a
vocation pray for a vocation what's a
vocation I'll pray for you stop hitting
me
purple vocation oh man could you imagine
all right sorry that's that's such a
left turn just different worlds of
movies after that who no I don't think
anybody would have took up that space no
right I can't I mean I just I just can't
see it if you guys did it yeah and you
know people try to imitate nobody tried
to imitate that
nobody even attempted to imitate that
because it was such an unlikely Source a
Chicano and a half [__] or the cult
Counter Culture Representatives nah
that's not him you know but actually
that was yeah they met in Canada
presented that you know in Canada
yeah so it's like you know because the
first thing Tommy and I thought the
first time we saw each other met each
other for the first time we both
thinking the same thought what are you
what are you the Mongolian biker kind of
deal I don't know and he was thinking
the same thing what is it left Filipino
or like I know
didn't know and you were in Canada
because you were dodging the draft that
was half of it right the other half I
agree with you I would have left you
yeah the other half was that I was a
Potter a professional Potter
my last semester in in college I took a
pottery class
because I I just had you know these
other classes to fill out my card and
you know the ones you've been putting
off for four years
econ 101 you know now and so I was going
to take all these classes and I was
standing in line to get these classes
and this girl who I knew from high
school and and uh she was next we said
she said what are you taking I said I
don't know I'm looking for something she
said well I'm gonna take Pottery take it
with me I say oh okay what time so went
and took the Potter class and the first
time I got my hands on clay and centered
a piece of clay
hooked that was it that was it I quit
all my other classes I quit my job I got
a 900 NADA and all I did was Pottery it
was like my Mexican jeans came bumping
out you know like and that's all I did I
was gonna be a Potter and I was I was on
my way to Canada to be assistant
eventually for this very famous Potter
uh Edgar hancheck
and he was he had won the bicentennial
exhibition award that your eye got there
which was it was a big deal and I was
just his assistant in the in the in the
foothills of the Rockies in Canada and
the Canadian Rockies so that's why I
went there but at the same time when my
in my last semester in college I was a
member of the draft resistance movement
under David Harris and so we were
causing all kinds of [__] you know we
were a lot of protests in the draft
board and then burning and
and uh so uh General Hershey who was the
director of the draft at the time said
anybody did any of those things that we
all did who were going to be immediately
reclassified I was a student a
reclassified drafted and sent to the
front lines of Vietnam and that was his
his fix that actually happened man I
don't know no [__] and so and so I I
was still 2s I was a student but I it
was gonna and when it got changed to 1A
I was still in school I was doing school
and this opportunity to go to Canada be
a Potter
came up at the same time so I said well
I'm gonna I'm gonna wait for these guys
to make a decision in Canada
not in not in Leavenworth in Canada and
so that's what I did I lived in Canada
for the next
a little over three years
and that's where I met Tommy in
Vancouver and eventually made it to
Vancouver
what an unlikely situation you never you
know you never know I was happy he was
the happiest time in my life I'm you
know I lived alone by myself in a little
cabin on a river and went to the river
every day for my water and chopped wood
and cold and and shot bears and [__] man
what I'm not sure man uh it was uh
because the guy who I worked for Ed he
was a very Avid Hunter he's Ukrainian
you know and he was just out in the
woods and he was a really great great
Potter but he was a hunter you know and
he went he hunted everything that was
you know within within rightful distance
from Australia
yeah where's that movie I you know that
was so interesting we pitched it a
couple of times oh yeah going for it
okay we just never made it wow yeah but
but I moved and the hairs under the uh
it's supposed to happen I when I went to
Canada I moved to exactly the place
where Tommy was raised in Canada in the
outside in Calgary
to the exact same neighborhood
you know and okay and I started hearing
these stories about this guy Tommy Chong
who had written his famous r b song does
your mama know about me and Blobby is a
great musician from there everybody knew
him from that and then he went to
Vancouver
and that's where I met him in Vancouver
and then you I've heard the story you
met at a topless bar you were performing
yeah theater yeah it was his family's
bar oh well I didn't know that yeah yeah
he he Tommy always started nightclubs so
that he would have some place for his
band to play he's always in bands he was
in a band since he was a little kid
play play r b Blues blah blah blah and
uh so he always had nightclips and so
when
eventually his band got discovered by
Motown and got signed to Motown uh he
went on the road and he left the club
that he was currently doing in the care
of his parents who immediately turned in
the bar
and so when he came back off the road uh
you know is this okay this is the
topless bar now and in the meantime he
had seen improvisational theater when he
was on the road he'd seen Second City in
Chicago the committee in San Francisco
and a couple other places and
when he got back to Vancouver he says I
want to do improv theater I'm done with
being a musician right now and uh I'm
gonna do improv theater but here in this
club uh so we're gonna we're gonna keep
the top of the settlement because that
keeps everybody coming in but we're
going to do improv integrate improv
theater in that and and the girl said
okay
you're not a strippers anymore
Oh I thought you meant like in between
no no no no no no no man Crystal you're
an actress okay
I swear to God that's what happened and
so and so I I it was it was starting to
go you know and and a mime artist and
this was the [__] toughest bar in
town I mean it's Chinatown Vancouver
Maine and penders
still to this day junkieville winoville
a tough tough place
you know
and so we changed it we changed the show
on the audience the audience didn't
change it was still bikers
and guys coming out of the woods
hadn't seen a girl in three years you
know uh and and we sent out the first
bill was a mime artist you know
[Laughter]
the girls I guess I wasn't there at the
beginning but and they would do little
skits fully dressed
you know in their street clothes because
Tommy said they when the girls came to
work they'd always look hot in their
street clothes you know little you know
bell bottoms and lower right and but and
when they had their stripper costumes on
they look less sexy you know
so and so they would do some skit in
which during the skit they would start
to take off their clothes and before
when the guys weren't even looking at it
and then they come out and dance you
know some they had a band and they're
dancing every once in a while they
glance up and and but at this they're
glued they were glued to the stage man
it's like watching these girls slowly
take off their clothes it was this whole
other experience man and there's some
music going on and then there was other
actors coming in you know guys coming
out long haired guys talking to them
while these girls are taking off their
clothes and and they didn't know what to
do
I didn't know whether to get mad or get
hard
so it was it was this interesting
combination and then I met Tommy I was
introduced to him by some other guy and
and I started writing for the group he
hired me as a writer because I told him
I was this great improv actor from LA
and I did I've given this whole [__]
line of uh you know credits it was total
[__] but he bought it and so I
started writing for the group and I did
him I wrote him a couple skills they did
right away you know okay cool and so
then I was watching the show and I would
do all this Parts when you know somebody
could make him
then the troop fell apart uh because all
the all them people wanted to go to the
hills to get their heads together I had
been to the hills my head was together
my pocketbook wasn't together you know
so Tommy and I stayed together and and
formed this Duo
what an unlikely situation my whole life
is unlikely dude I mean it's really who
would who would have thought oh not not
you 11 getting ready to go pray for your
whole life yeah you'd be a topless bar
as like a as a Potter yeah
we saw a bear right in front of the
studio I didn't she was dead dead man
it's right in front of the studio I've
been I've been working all day you know
making stuff and he's been throwing all
day and he went on to take a stretching
and it comes running in and he throws
the door and locks the door and it's
like a big studio with floor-to-ceiling
the windows and looking out over there
and
I need to start hello is that what wife
Emma where's my gun where's my gun and
she finally finds it and his wife was
another thing he starts popping bullets
in it or popping up and he's running
across the street right here Here Comes
This Bear man you're running towards the
studio man I'm like and I'm sitting
there waging Clan what the and he opens
the door then it pops it right right in
front of the studio man like
is
still twitching away and and steam
coming off it man
and and it says okay I'll grab that back
foot and come over here and drag it down
in the room what the drug what no man
bear is still twitching and and it's no
we got to pull it out of skin it you
know because we just grab that thing we
got it grab this man down into a Ravine
and then he had something strung it up
between between two trees with the thing
and hoisted it up he says okay the first
cut goes right here chill
and I'm saying I'm right from Hollywood
and Vine dude man I can never look at it
I never shot a gun or been outside of my
door and uh
okay
I guess this is the Wilderness man I
could you know be on naked and alone you
know or whatever alone and Afraid man
it's crazy how life is you could you
could be
eating it like Nick's burgers in East
L.A the or get eaten by a bear a couple
months later you know I've often thought
of that so the very same thing a couple
different turns in your life or
opportunities present themselves
differently or there's or doesn't don't
present themselves your life is totally
different or make your opportunity by
saying you're the Improv guy from La
yeah yeah sometimes it needs you just
need that little it's all being centered
and and trusting your intuition and the
more you do things to hone your
intuition
the the better your choices will be and
if it's had some discipline that you do
I've I've meditated since I was
19. really daily daily wow and right
when you wake up I'm assuming a little
after yeah
where am I and
then in the evening too before you start
your evening activity activities uh and
I'm done Tai Chi for many many years and
and You Know It Centers you
uh throwing Clay is a centering
technique once you feel that that Center
when you when you get a clay right on
center
it's like that it feels like that almost
like a frequency of some time
and it's just your whole body gets
centered do you still do Pottery uh no
it's I can't stand centering anymore and
so
no it's it's a process you know a lot of
stages and you have to be there oh just
too much and I'm always traveling I love
doing it when I did it
[Music]
I'll tell you how organic so I was I
mean I had no contact with nature
whatsoever you know on the trees and the
thing oh sorry could you move the mic
just a little closer it started to cut
out okay I was in now you can we can
move it too if you want no no okay so
anyways when I got there at this place
where I where I made the pottery brag
Creek Alberta
and and it was during the summer and so
the guys at the at at the trading store
they had made this this bridge that went
across the river and it was on car track
our car tires and they pushed it out in
the river during the summer and you
could walk over the river and blah blah
blah
in the winter you couldn't so I I had to
go to the river for my water every day
you know and and so I I I had this
little wagon with a like a I guess it
was a 25 gallon drum you know and I have
to go in there and fill the drum by hand
and put in the thing take it back I said
man this is this is [__] it's taking
forever I got this bright idea what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna take the the canister
to the bridge and then hang it over the
bridge and just pull and it'll fill up
that way okay sounds like a great idea
get there poop get on the bridge Lord as
soon as it hit the water pulled me off
the bridge and I'm gone man and this
water is cold like you wouldn't believe
like heart stopped being cold like and
fast and I was like I'm gone I'm fully
clothed cowboy boots
and you can't catch your breath you're
like
that's how I oh this is it you know this
is this is it this is going to be a
priest
and and I waited till we got down the
river I we got down the river a little
bit and it widened so the the current
wasn't Swift and I made a break for the
shore man as hard as I could swim and I
made it to the the thing like
Welcome To Nature
nature is fast and cold
we're horrifying oh where is this movie
I see all of these things I see and all
I see is a red beanie and a kind nature
that's what I'm seeing in my head it was
it was literally that man I have no
experience you know the people that grow
up in the cold take for granted you know
oh man all right well that was oh Mom I
feel like I just watched the movie it's
like Homeward violent type show yeah
so I want to get into your uh your art
well your your um the Cheech Marin
Chicano art museum correct in Riverside
yeah Riverside yeah when did you start
that and how does it feel to have your
name on the side of a building cool
every time I go buy it it's cool
no it lights up cool
um
it's it's the end of a long journey you
know at the beginning of another New
Journey but uh I was interested in art
from a very early age those cousins I
was telling you about the one that was
went on to be uh Harvard and young and
done and we were all part of this group
uh this little group and the head cousin
Louie uh uh brilliant guy and he
assigned us all topics to learn about
and bring back to the group
and I got art and she go learn about art
and bring it back what you know show to
everybody okay so I was
maybe 10 oh 10 yeah and uh and so I went
to the library and started taking all
the up looking at pictures okay that's
Picasso and that's Michelangelo so I was
I was you know educated in art from very
early age and so I started going to
museums at the same time because you to
really enjoy paintings you have to go to
museums you have to see them live you
know so I won't get into it but you
should
but uh so I was interested and then when
I got enough money I started buying art
and at some point I discovered these
Chicano pain has that already been
discovered you know but but you for
yourself you discovered yeah exactly and
I started collecting their work and uh I
I knew what they were doing because I
was educated and I see the basis on
which they were building and their
Mexican heritage you know coming
together with all kinds of other
influences because they all went to uh
either
prestigious art schools or universities
I mean you know they're all really
educated in art and I could see that in
in what they were doing so
started doing that and but I I was
always a an inventor collector collector
or something all my life uh baseball
cards marbles buttons matchbook covers
almost baseball cards are the first
things I ever collected in my life yeah
yeah baseball cards was good
and you learn a lot about collecting you
know how to organize things you know put
them in files what is good what is bats
you know so all that stuff
and so when I got to the Chicanos uh I
knew a lot about collecting so and I
traveled that's the key so you're seeing
things from all over the world yeah all
over you know and all over the U.S the
same thing with I clicked at our new
vote for a long time and but I traveled
so you could pick up pieces all over him
and then and I was that guy with a lamp
on his on his lap in the airplane
bringing stuff at home I don't feel as
bad now I buy so much art it's it's a
problem yeah well and it's a problem but
see you've been doing it your whole life
I don't feel it but I've been doing
since I was a kid I just like it yeah I
know I took art history for like six
years in school yeah just something I
like I don't know I just I just can't
draw though yeah he's a canal I can't
draw at all so I was like I appreciate
people that can at least have you ever
seen Rob the original on Instagram he's
a Mexican artist no oh he's amazing he
makes art out of literally I mean he'll
make it out of broken glass or like
he'll shave it in hair you can make
every medium basically he can just
create something this is yeah that's you
know artists
what makes us keep going forward you
know the unattainable that it's really
attainable you know so
is there any piece that you have that's
like your favorite or really no it's
like picking your favorite kid yeah the
one that's bugging you the least
so with your music your Museum you can
anybody can just go yeah okay so in
Riverside and you can just go and just
view the art it's like an actual art
museum that has your name on it which is
insane yeah which is insane wow you know
it's that there were again it's a and
there's a matter of trust in your
instincts because I've been doing this
for a long time I was
close to 50 years and and and the
collections played in over 50 museums
that's just a collection I'm from the
Smithsonian to every as she plays as you
curate the whole thing uh no I have
curator
Salon process but and museums are highly
political institutions highly and
because they represent the official
imprimatur of cultural acceptance you
know it's in a museum
you got to trust it you know I mean
here's what the history is getting into
this point and so they're very you know
everybody's got an opinion about where
that point is you know and and funds
from the community are usually involved
or private funds so it's all that
so you get to the end of collecting and
or you think
and what do I do with this thing I mean
you can't you can't keep it all under
the bed anymore in the closet or give it
to your sister or whatever
so I was at that point and we had done a
a show at the universe at the Riverside
Art Museum of from The Collection works
on paper
and we showed it there and it was a big
hit huge hit the biggest hit there
attendance wise they'd ever had
so they were
they had a building they had a repurpose
it was the town library and it's a
beautiful modernist building I mean it's
beautiful modernist and they had to give
it do something else with it or else
knock it down and build something else
and uh the town manager noticed the fact
that we had this huge show there found
out about the rest of the collection and
he proposed that they give me the museum
in exchange for the collection
and at first I didn't understand where
you want me to buy a museum I'm doing
okay I don't know if I'm Museum rich
I don't make money in my sleep you know
uh but no no no we want to give you the
museum not you personally but a space we
will dedicate for the me for the
collection that's the only thing we'll
play in there is that collection
and you have to decide
fairly quickly because they'll move on
to somebody else or knock the building
down
uh that means giving them the collection
once you give it to them it's theirs
yeah you know oh they keep it it's not
like a license no it's a gift to them oh
wow and so I had to make that decision
right then and I decided that the best
use of the collection was that everybody
got to see it you know and so anytime I
wanted to go visit the collection
I could it's right down there I mean I
kept a small portion for my family you
know but usually smaller things that I
like to have around me and but the I
think it was 550 pieces oh I got to
there and but the joy and the the access
the community has to that now is you
couldn't buy that no you can't couldn't
buy that you know it's it's selflessness
and at the same time it's like whatever
Whoopi Goldberg and she's giving the
check in in a in ghost she almost
doesn't let it go that's how I would be
with all my paintings yeah all right you
can have it you know it you saw that the
biggest the
most good was going to be to do that of
course you know and it's like it I am
fully gratified that the reaction is
gone and uh at least the first year we
were open we've been open a year now uh
um during that year we were judged one
of the 50 top music shows in the world
that year a museum only been open six
months it's a big deal yeah it's a big
deal and as as an artist not not even
all these other things you know you're
Cheech and Chong you're doing born in
East L.A you're doing out with it's an
art thing that you've been having since
before you even knew you're gonna be an
actor yeah exactly so it's a lifelong
some summary of like this is what I've
been collecting in my existence here
yeah yeah all right I could see why you
gave it to him now yeah you know because
I had that experience because we put I
mean in when you shorten 50 museums you
go to a lot of museums and that's
unheard of for a private collection
because they don't want to do that
museums do not want to do that because
and I understand why because you your
their curatorial power their curatorial
power lies them being able to say what
shows go in there and how it's arranged
and blah blah blah what pieces do go in
what pieces don't go in but
you know they don't want to do that and
I understand because their fear is that
you're going to use their Museum to
raise the uh the Visage of York uh
collection and then sell it for a woman
I've never done that I've never sold a
piece ever and it wasn't my intention to
do that and and once they get over that
okay if there's a certain amount of
trust from them you know because because
nobody none of these guys wanted to put
their head in the block first the museum
directors and say this is officially
Chicano art
oh because in case somebody else comes
and yeah trumps that cargo yeah well now
you look like you don't know what you're
talking about yeah and that and for a
director to give the okay to all right
bring the show in this is it it's
putting his head in the block man yeah
and that Bladen might might come down
real quick because they're highly in uh
uh political institutions luckily it
didn't you know and then we started
what's the first Museum
everything went well
you know uh because but there was a lot
of feedback you know I mean at the
beginning not from the sources that you
would expect from the Chicano
intellectual community
uh the the professors at the at the
universities and and we like you as a
comedian but who you could come in and
say what's up with Chicano artists amen
I have unpaid student loans
how are we going to do that and so that
was that you know and Chicana work
should only be political art you know
and that's what we opened the show in
San Antonio at the Museum there
um there was a lot of feedback and so
all right anybody's got anything to say
tomorrow morning Saturday morning made
it at 9 30 in order to weed out a bunch
of people yeah these guys ain't gonna
make it tonight and so as I said 9 30.
anybody has got anything to say about
Pro or con and I that's the time in
everybody so he opened up and then I was
on the dice and a couple other artists
John Valadez from LA and and Linda
velejo and the boards of uh of of the
museum and all the all the audience
and young kids they want their art scene
and and then the debate raised back and
forth and blah blah blah and and as soon
as the kind of veterans saw that they
were losing you know like went back and
so at the end this this one uh elderly
lady who looked like she'd seen
everything Chicano in in San Antonio I
have one question for John Valadez
after everything you've heard here going
back and forth do you still consider
yourself a Chicano painter
and he and he looked up to the heavens
and he says
only if it bothers you
[Laughter]
my hero my hero Heckler he is
like and and that is kind of the essence
of Chicano art it's defiant you know
it's defiant in the face of of political
correctness sometimes you know so and so
open for interpretation like you're
saying The Chopping Block yeah it's it's
just it's everything is arts and opinion
it is you know people might say this is
looks like a kid dude I think it was
cool yeah it's everything is open so I
can see how that wow you gotta know a
whole different world of
having to be like I'm not just a
comedian I'm like I'm a human that was
that was it was unfortunate actually my
image worked against me and trying to
gain validity in this world and that in
the art world you know
you but but then again they like the
community
ready to give me a kind of coupons and
then when they start opening the crates
that's when it changed oh of course oh
my God what ingrate you sent your stuff
in like the movies how does that feel
you know what I mean it's like dress I
really am that dude
the first show we did was at the at the
San Antonio Museum and I was in the
loading dock when they brought the
crates in and they said and as they were
still suspicious man that I was pulling
some kind of scam and and they brought
the creation and started unloading them
and opening them and that's when it
changed I mean like and and they start
taking the paintings out they start
looking at them and then I saw people
would couple people would disappear from
the room
they didn't like them okay well [__] you
you know and then and then they and they
would come back and they had more people
with them they've been going on and then
this happened again it's more pennies a
couple other people would disappearing
and they come back with a plate missile
all of a sudden it's like okay this is
no [__] you know so this is the real
[__] and so
it changed until then after that it
became easier then we got the
Smithsonian that was the Nexus was the
next Museum and then after that most
valid thing ever the young in San
Francisco uh the
so what's it the Weissman in Minneapolis
they're all big museums you know they
were so 100 now credible after they open
that opened those crates Now You See Me
Now you do stuff
so what is that you're technically like
an is that like an art director is that
the name for somebody who owns pieces
and places something like that just a
collect her okay
a humble collector in the woods
just a bear attack Survivor they're
attack Survivor I love that Marty I'm
just getting out of the draft here
that's crazy that that's what they did
like oh you guys want to have a defiant
Club you're going first that's insane no
no no no everybody oh that sounds good
to us yeah
but no everybody in my side of it knew
that was the first to miss Amendment
issue would be
undoubtedly overturned we hope uh and it
was and it went to the I can know what
the circuit is here in California in L.A
but it went there and got thrown out
yeah get out of here
they sent me in another notice for
physical that same week this is three
years you know almost three and a half
years later
I'm writing jokes for these guys on
stage so I
when I was in in Canada I was living in
Banff I lived there for about a year and
and I had broken my leg skiing severely
a compound fractured seven you know and
and so I go that's it so I sent from I
used my last forty dollars on the world
same from my x-rays from the hospital in
Banff they sent them back down
went to the the physical with my little
folder with x-rays under my arm and I
was standing in a big room with all
these guys in their underwear and we're
sitting around waiting and the door
opens up here comes a doctor out of this
door and he's smoking came out for a
smoke break with a stethoscope
and he sees me across them he says hey
you good come here and I walk over it
says it looks at my leg it says
eligible for the draft
okay okay that's so sad sorry I'm gonna
cry
it's just the universe working with you
at that point you have to trust your
instincts go go to the thing you'll pass
it you know go to the thing because guys
were doing everything they could to get
out yeah yeah physically some people
probably broke their leg on purpose
while doing what you love I was scared
that's why you could be being a skier
while being Chicano at the same time man
that's what you get honestly when you
said I thought you were like really
those are your dues man we know you have
a you have to you have a heart out today
okay but I wanted to ask a question that
I think a lot of people would ask
in Up in Smoke when you guys roll that
giant joint right yeah I rolled a
somewhat of a small a little guy today
were any of those joints real were you
guys smoking on set ever that's one
question I know everyone wants to know
no that was always that's all stunt dope
stunt Dome oh that sounds like a brand
so is it only on the off cameras that's
happening uh well Tommy Smokes on camera
not on camera no because it's too long a
day
yeah yeah you work you know you work 18
hours a day man and then you're gonna
sit around getting stoned all day I
ain't gonna work that's truish yeah yeah
I get it you know what on you on tour
you're okay hour a night oh oh okay I
get it that's it you know a movies
yeah three o'clock in the morning okay
we're gonna do your close-up now
okay that makes sense yeah so speaking
of tour do you have any crazy acid
stories
yeah
[Music]
you're making which one
can I actually say when the FCC won't
close you down uh
there was one that we played we played
this rock festival the Bull Island
Indiana and outside of Chicago was the
big Midwest rock festival after
Woodstock and Altamonte and the right
was right in that area
and we're gonna try one of these they
hadn't I mean it was the early days they
have no idea how to technologically how
to pull pull this big thing off and so
they expected they wanted to get a
hundred thousand people they get 500
000. oh my God and you couldn't see the
end of them you know in the First Act
was supposed to go on it at noon the
First Act went on at midnight oh no and
so the First Act was this this all girl
band called uh
uh
uh Bertha Bertha and it was La Band rock
band Hard Rock Band great
great players great singers and yeah
that my favorite t-shirt says Bertha has
balls
all the time and so so at midnight uh
finally the festival goes on and there's
like really literally 500 000 people you
couldn't see physically see the end of
them you your eyesight wouldn't go that
far and it was midnight and they had
been they had time their drugs for noon
you know
people out asleep people there was just
like and then there's everybody like in
skins and totem poles and hopping up and
down on one two leagues and so anyways
okay and that was her birthday thank you
very much and now oh so
as soon as Bertha gets off the stage
a cloudburst of biblical proportions
opened up on these poor people
as hard as I've ever seen it rain in my
life
and we looked at and where the stage is
really high so you could really look uh
down on the not literally but uh you
know and they're like
and and and it just rained I mean hard
hard rain and neighbors and then and and
the promoters in their and they're
farsighted and this had had erected over
the stage of parachute as like an awning
to protect the bands from the sun when
the thing was supposed to start at noon
but not at midnight so as as a result of
this downpour there was a swimming pool
over our heads and I was hoping that
this this parachute was gonna hold
because we had to walk out under it and
those were the most dangerous work
environment ever and it was puddles all
over the stage man you know and they
didn't have no you know wireless mics in
those days you know you had a golden
grab the thing like it shocked and so
but how are you gonna communicate the
500 000 people there's no screens
there's no nothing man there's just
where's that voice there's voices coming
song
I know the hairless ever for Cheech and
Chong and there was a like a steady drip
coming off the end of the parachute so
it was like a waterfall playing in
Trader Vicks or something
[Laughter]
it was absurd it was an absurd situation
so we I started doing coin tricks
disappearing coin tricks hey just hey
where'd it go
you know and I'm telling them and I'm
walking them through it I'm telling them
I'm walking over to this side of the
stage now okay follow my voice
is that big
and crapping it hasn't happened it'll
happen again yeah that like crowd and
then we did anything we could do just
visually that you didn't need any words
for we did all this anything that you
know it was cool all on acid well not us
but um
okay that's why I thought we were
leaving it too wow that's not what year
was that in the past in the past that's
the best answer I think anybody can get
when was this in the past you know it's
like that's it I don't know early 70s
before you read movies even it's just
all records at this point we had just
had our first record yeah wow yeah
that's the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
now I understand what you're saying
you're playing live in front of these
500 000 crowds
come on come on somebody out there come
on wake up here you're doing nominated
Harry wake up you know I was like I
can't I I can't believe it I just you
know and they know that we want to be
you will then yeah Tommy was there at
the beginning of rock and roll man when
when blues and stuff turned into rock
and roll he was right there and playing
in bands you know so with uh uh Bo
Diddley and Chuck Berry and uh you know
Little Richard at the last check mark
you need I think before in the Arts
world yeah you know you don't need it
but a little
thank you yeah yeah a little you know I
made my first record when I was five
years old my first record
I was I was this little kid that could
sing in tune
uh squeaky little voice but I could sing
Mexican songs in tune uh you know but
and so my mother had this friend who has
a little record company that sold
records in the neighborhood and so he
recorded me
[Music]
and he was a guitar player and he played
behind me
but if I Resort said and at that point
and it kind of made me Showbiz you know
that's where I'm going nice
awesome well I know I know we have well
you got to get you out of here but I
think we could go for days here oh this
is so legendary thank you for this thank
you it feels so right it was great and
for everyone out there the next stuff
coming out that next up coming out is
the chicheladas
at the woods on Friday between two and
five also anywhere you go to
dispensaries even legal states any legal
State look for chicha stash brand
teacher stash or Cheech and Chong now
we're Amalgamated now for the first time
we're together we have a Cheech and Tong
Brands cheat Grand and a Chong brand
Specialty Products on either on all
sides yeah yeah so it's it's doing well
I mean the thing is about celebrity
brands in this field just got to be able
to hang in there yeah it's still alive
still float you know until they get more
you know legal uh National passage of it
then it'll really really change but you
know stay afloat as you're going down
the river
almost died that was a shock of my life
man
you're going to man uh well thank you
this was this was fun this was great
this was everything thank you so much
appreciate you
um Marty anything else before we get
here no I just really appreciate it I
know the fans are so excited this was
just something that had to happen for us
one of our top episodes so thank you oh
thank you thank you very much my
pleasure we appreciate you okay so for
everybody this is Marty Cheech Marin and
I have a dope ass day
that was very fun that was awesome thank
you thank you very much
[Music]